hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll I'm
not sure if everyone knows but I have
mentioned sometimes on Twitter I keep a
list of the Twitter feeds of all
previous mindscape guests who are on
Twitter so you can it's a public list
you can go and you can subscribe to it
or check out who's on there Etc it's
kind of enlightening you know I it helps
me keep track of what is being said by
all the former guests and I've since I
followed that list uh one of the people
on it is Theodore ornov who was our
guest some time ago who talked about
crispr and Gene editing a wonderful
molecular biologist and on Twitter
recently he got very very excited
Theodore started talking about this new
result that is going to rewrite the
biology textbooks it's very very
exciting and that result is what we're
going to talk about today it has to do
with a little kind of protein called a
histone I had think I had heard of
histones before this appeared on Twitter
but I didn't really know any thing about
them the point is that in a human being
or other you know fairly mature
organisms we have DNA the DNA carries
our genetic information and there's a
lot of it there's a lot of genetic
information to be carried so if you were
to take a single DNA strand from a human
being and stretch it out it would be
something like 1.8 meters long that's
very long and we have to squeeze it into
the cell uh the nucleus of a cell in our
body every single cell that we have so
how do we do that the answer is that the
DNA wraps itself tightly around these
little proteins called histones so
histones are the backbone or the spool
if you like that you spin the thread
around that keeps the DNA organized and
because it's biology and biology is
always complicated the individual units
around which the DNA wrap to to do this
are called nucleosomes and then the
nucleosomes are put into these fibers
that form chromatin and these are all
what make up your chromosomes Etc I
could never remember all these words
that's why I became a physicist but so
clearly histones are very important they
help organize the DNA and because it's
biology and everything serves multiple
purposes they also help regulate the
expression of the DNA the histones are
not just sitting there they're not
actually like spools in thread they have
a functional role to play here
so if you go to Wikipedia and you look
up his Stone as you can bet that I did
the first line says in biology histones
are highly basic proteins that are found
in eukaryotic cell nuclei so remember
back in your biology days I don't know
my biology days in high school were too
long ago so the field has moved on since
then but these days we talk about Three
Kingdoms of Life we talk about bacteria
Archaea and the eukaryotes the
eukaryotes are the group that have
nucleus in the cell and there's a
complicated history because there's they
also have mitochondria and the
pre-history of life was you know quite
uh you know people slept around a lot
all these little cells there's a lot of
interchange of DNA and things going on
so the boundaries back in the Primitive
forms between bacteria Archaea and
eukaryotes are a little bit fuzzy
sometimes but you can tell the
difference so we could media is telling
you that these histones are a eukaryotic
phenomenon but it turns out you can find
some in archaea also and the new
discovery is you can even find them in
bacteria
what does that mean why is that
important why do the textbooks need to
be Rewritten because of this discovery
you've come to the right place I came
into this having no idea the answer to
these questions but we found an expert
Tobias varnica today's guest is one of
the authors on the new paper and so he's
going to explain to us and you know
because it's supposed to be educational
here we get into a lot of the basic
structure of the cell and the role that
that plays in evolutionary biology in
addition to the new discovery about
histones so for those of you like me
whose high school biology class was a
long time ago this is the perfect
podcast episode to listen to let's go
foreign
[Music]
Tobias varnica welcome to the mindscape
podcast hello thanks for having me you
know I'm going to start very basic uh as
a more of a physics person than a
biology person I hope that you'll
forgive me how basically we start and
we'll get into some deep Waters here but
remind us what eukaryotes are for
example nice start with a false modesty
or physicist and I was intimidated by
having talked to a physicist because
clearly they know much more than I do
but eukaryotes are one branch of the
tree of life if you want and they are
set apart from other organisms like
bacteria mainly by the fact that they
have what is called a nucleus right so a
compartment within the cell in which the
genetic material so DNA is stored that's
the that's main distinction and so as
opposed to things without nuclei so
that's that would be bacteria which many
people will be familiar with and another
group called Arc here that if you think
about morphology often look quite
similar to bacteria so they're
single-celled organisms they have
typically circular genomes
unlike eukaryotes but they don't have a
nucleus right what's interesting in
evolutionary terms is that Archaea are
actually more closely related to
eukaryotes than they are to bacteria so
although they look a bit different the
Machinery that you find in the cell
Machinery that does the copying of the
genetic information that keeps the cell
going is in many instances more closely
related to what we see in eukaryotes
like me and you and plants and flies and
fungi so if they're all unicellular and
have no nuclei what is the difference
between archaea and bacteria and it was
a fairly recent historically speaking
development that we even distinguish
between these right yeah so it's true we
only really learned about the sort of
fundamental distinction between the two
from sequencing their genomes because
they're morphologically so similar
people just thought they archaea would
be weird bacteria
um so really it's just by looking at the
The genome sequence trying to map out
the evolutionary relationships that
people realize that there's a key
Machinery
including ribosomal rnase or ribosomes
are
um the machines in the cell that make
proteins so the ribosomal RNA is
actually more closely related to
eukaryotes than to bacteria and that
you're right it's very recent oh like
well in historical terms quite recent
observation services in the 70s and then
people decided to work it out in the 80s
anything while I was alive counts as a
recent scientific advance
[Laughter]
I think that's the objective truth so is
it possible I'm skipping way ahead here
but given that we only identified an
entire Kingdom of life within my
lifetime you know what is the chance
that we're not done yet that this whole
idea that there are three kingdoms is
not even the final answer that's a super
interesting question and I don't quite
know how to answer that so the one thing
that we haven't mentioned is is viruses
and things that many people wouldn't
count as organisms because they need
some other cell to to replicate in
um but people again quite recently a bit
more recently even than the arcade
people have started to to find viruses
that are actually really quite large
encoding thousands of genes
um so how they exactly fit in between a
care and bacteria and eukaryotes and
whether you can call them organisms I
guess you could you could ask that
question the second point I think that's
worth making is that
especially with the onset of sort of
large-scale sequencing of genomes we've
started to characterize their diversity
of Life much better and it can still be
allocated to bacteria archaea eukaryotes
but obviously we we only know what we
are we'll only recognize what we what we
can see empirically through the methods
that we use
so if there is a life form that for some
reason is resistant to us seeing it
through the sequencing approach then
then maybe there is something out there
that maybe not defies the classic
categorization but maybe must blurs the
boundaries a bit and it might be
something that even we already know
exists we just don't understand how
different it is I mean it sounds like
that's the case with the archaea that we
discovered something about them after we
discovered their existence so so that's
true but I think it's also fair to say
that if we know it exists based on sort
of visual observation we are now very
good at obtaining the genetic material
in those cells
um so I'm not aware of anything I mean
if there had been a case where that that
was true I think I would have heard of
it
um
um but yeah so I think what's what's
maybe possible is that there's something
that has been unobserved both at the
morphological level or just you know
visualizing the cell and at the genetic
level but sort of the the unknown
unknowns if you want good yeah okay so
we have um eukaryotes and prokaryotes
and the prokaryotes are divided up into
bacteria and archaea the other piece of
very Elementary information I wanted to
get on the table is how we carry our
genetic information you know back in my
day there was a central dogma of uh how
DNA information went through RNA to
proteins Etc it seems to be more
complicated than that now I'm not sure
it's that much more complicated
um bacteria archaea eukaryotes
um all encode genetic information using
DNA there are some viruses that use RNA
but when you talk about the central
dogma if you mean that the information
when it comes to constructing the cell
flows from DNA to RNA to protein
um that is that is still largely true
and then there's some feedback
mechanisms that maybe mean that if you
have a protein that binds to DNA that
might affect how the how the DNA
operates right but the genetic
information when it comes to heredity is
still very much based on the DNA to DNA
I guess what I was thinking of and maybe
this is the wrong way of thinking of it
when I say more complicated the two
things that I did not learn when I took
my last biology class which was in high
school uh is number one that there's DNA
not only in the nucleus of our cell but
also in the mitochondria and Elsewhere
for Wii eukaryotes and number two that
that the expression of these DNA is
actually really important I mean maybe
you're making the distinction that
that's a functional thing not a sort of
design of the cell kind of difference
yeah so totally true so we have in many
organisms
um eukaryotes specifically
um multiple parts of the cell that can
hold DNA so you have the genomic DNA
that's encoded in the uh in the nucleus
then you have a contribution from
mitochondria and mitochondria used to be
bacteria that became associated with an
archaeon ancestrally but have retained
in most instances some of the DNA and
that DNA gets independently replicated
and passed on and then a similar thing
happens in Plants where you have
chloroplasts which you need for
photosynthesis they are also ancestrally
a different type of bacterium and they
also have their own DNA
um that they independently replicate and
pass on so yeah there's there's multiple
streams of genetic information that that
are happening in eukaryotes so
eukaryotes are really simple ions if you
want
um test for symbiosis uh between archaea
and bacteria well good that leads into
exactly where I wanted to go because I'm
curious about the evolutionary
relationship between uh these three
kingdoms we have here my impression is
that this is a very very active area of
study it is not it is not settled uh
like it like we might have hoped it
would be by now
um it's certainly very active and the
activity comes
um from the discovery that happened
around the 2000 early mid 2000s
um of some archaea called asgarda care
and those asgarda care uh intrigued
people because they happen to encode
many proteins that were associated with
eukaryotes or many many genes that were
associated with eukaryotes that you
wouldn't otherwise find in bacteria or
other care and if you again try to
reconstruct the ancestral relationships
between eukaryotes Archaea and bacteria
it turns out that these asgarda care
seem to be more closely related to
eukaryotes than any of the other archaea
that we previously knew about so people
got excited about that because they're
always hunting for what might be the
closest
archaeal organism that you could find
that might inform you about how
eukaryotes evolved and very recently
people actually have taken managed to
grow these in the lab and it's the first
group that accomplished that took years
to do that because we have to figure out
the growth conditions make them grow
make them happy isolate them from a
complex mixture of microbes and I guess
the most fascinating aspect of this was
that they they were not sort of round or
rot like cells but had long
noodle-like almost appendages and some
people had predicted that the closest
relatives to eukaryotes would have those
appendages because they thought that
bacteria might actually Nestle in with
the archaeal cell and over time this
association between bacteria that would
eventually become mitochondria and
archaea that would become the right
remainder of the cell would become
increasingly intimate until they started
forming one cell okay so we think so
people predicted that is this evidence
that it's true I didn't quite get the
connection so people have tried to make
models and try to understand how this
initial Association of an archaeon with
the bacterium would lead to what we now
recognize as a eukaryotic cell right
and to to put it
um so I've simply there's different
models of how people try to square the
fact that
mitochondria and the nucleus and the
outer membrane of eukaryotes are quite
different
um so how would that have evolved and
one of the models that uh explained that
is that actually the archaeal cell
started to envelop bacteria that were
initially maybe more loosely associated
exchanging nutrients but not in a
totally obligatory style okay
I guess something that I should have
asked maybe you've already answered but
it slipped by me
um is there a way of explaining what the
difference is between archaea and
bacteria if they're both prokaryotes uh
you say that it's a genetic difference
am I going to have to just trust you on
that or is there a way to explain what
the genetic difference is so it's I mean
I'm happy to just look if you just if
you just looked at them yeah there was
no obvious differences there's some
there's some components that are that
are different so for example
um bacteria I have
um a chemical element called called
peptidoglycan on their cell wall
um okay I don't have that there are
elements that samakia have bacteria
don't have
um but the distinction really comes from
the differences at the at the genetic
level okay the level of the sequence
okay so some basically all I can the
easiest way to explain this maybe that
some of the machines are recognizably
different and particularly the machines
that are that are key to running the
main processes in the cell such as
transcription translation replication
and those machines on the archaea side
are closer to what we see in eukaryotes
than the bacterial version yes correct
so some Plucky archaea back in the day
swallowed a bacteria and was that the
birth of eukaryotes or is it a something
we're a little sketchy about still well
that's the model how the details
happened
um is borderline impossible to say
um you can make a you can make a case
about whether something is consistent
with the evidence that we have whether
something is parsimonious but there's so
many variables that we don't know about
that I think that you will never be able
to reconstruct the the precise nature of
the event that happened okay that's fair
and the
cell nucleus itself
when was the first cell nucleus is that
I mean it's not I guess it's not quite
clear to me
um the relationship between this
archaeus swallowing of bacteria that
that helps me explain why there are sort
of substructures like mitochondria in a
eukaryotic cell I'm not sure exactly
where the cell nucleus itself originated
yeah I'm and I'm not an expert in that
at all so uh rather than getting
something wrong I'll decline on that
question okay that is perfectly Fair uh
let's go back to the Asgard archaea
which are number one hilarious because I
was reading up about them and they're
named after you know Heimdall and Loki
and Thor and everything so people took
the uh the consistency of the metaphor
very centrally and they're the ones that
are we think most related to we
eukaryotes so in in some sense almost a
missing link between regular Archaea and
uh eukaryotic life yeah you I'm not sure
whether you could
um use the word Missing Link but they're
the closest that we currently have to
what we think in ancestral
proto-eukaryote it might have looked
like prior to the association with
bacteria and there's something about the
amount of complexity in these particular
Asgardian archaea that that helps us
think that oh yeah I can see how maybe
I'm I'm saying things as if they're
statements but you can correct me if I'm
completely crazy uh that that allows for
a kind of phase transition to more
complex structures that is compatible
with what we might want out of the
original eukaryotic cells well so
initially when people
um looked at these archaea all they had
was genomes so from the genomes you can
reconstruct what proteins are encoded in
those genomes and then you have to make
a leap of faith to say actually the
protein I find here that I also found in
eukaryote does exactly the same thing
and it does as it does and you carry it
okay and it and it might not
so what
um I think would have emboldened people
and rightly so is the fact that now that
we can visualize
um what those cells look like directly
visualize and can grow them in the lab
that some of those predictions actually
appear to have become true so for
example
um they were predicted to have a complex
arguably more eukaryotic like
cytoskeleton so structure within the
cell that gives its shape and allows it
to change its shape
and that was indeed observed okay I
should stress I should stress that these
results are so recent and one of the key
papers here was literally published a
few weeks ago that we're really at the
beginning of this journey to understand
to what extent the similarities that we
see at the level of the genome really
translate into similarities that we sell
at the see at the level of cell
architect future cell function an
interaction with say bacteria right
about which we know very little at the
moment so please do tell us you know
what the dates of this these things are
because uh you know part of me thinks
that uh one learns things in high school
or college and then a typical person who
is not uh an Aficionado of the field
just sort of gets their knowledge stuck
there so I'm rewriting a lot of what I
thought was true about the evolution of
life as I talked to real biologists
about these kinds of things
um yeah that's I when I was at school I
also got a very misleading question that
basically all the big questions have
been answered Oh no just you could just
you know all you did was uh scrape
around uh ornamentally at the surface a
little bit
um but also the the one of the papers I
mentioned uh was published
um I think in January
um so yeah um it's a second
visualization
um of one of those a second successful
uh culture of one of those Asgard
strained it's called lokiakim osiferum
and now that people can grow them and
can grow them a bit more efficiently
than having to wait for five to ten
years to get something that you can
visualize now people can start doing
interesting things biochemistry look at
the the sort of internal processes of
the cell how are genes transcribed how
are they made into proteins so really
we're just starting to to get to all
those questions
um through our ability to to grow these
Critters are the actual archaea all over
the place or is it like bacteria where
you know the bacteria in me Etc or there
are things that you have to really go to
Exotic locations to find some so that's
what people used to think
um and the reason for that so initially
they were found in acidic Lakes
um
hydrothermal vents
places where many other things don't
survive so Ikea were thought to be in
the main extremophiles so Yellowstone
for example was a big source of of Ikea
um as I mentioned hydrothermal vents
acid
drainage from mines so weird places it
turns out that actually now that we have
the Technologies to look much more
sensitively
in all kinds of environments Ikea are
pretty much everywhere okay but off but
often in very low abundance so that in
the past we weren't sensitive enough to
detect them
or because our technology was maybe
biased towards detecting what we already
knew so bacteria so you find archaea in
the soil you find vast amounts of
archaea in the sea you find archaea in
the human guts
in me
they are chances are they are
um in your gut
um on your skin
um and again probably in quite low
abundance and for most of them we don't
know what role they play
um in interacting with bacteria or
yourself
um but they're there so we know for
example that they're quite abundant in
the gut of termites and also in
um in ruminants
um and so they're probably playing
playing important roles there in um in
processing
um the food stuff that these creatures
eat
so benefiting to the extent that we
human beings you know like to classify
things and keep things simple is it more
accurate to say that the eukaryotes
evolved out of archaea or that it's
better to just separate them off because
of this symbiotic thing where both
Archaea and bacteria were involved so if
I had to pick between the two I would
say the latter because I think
eukaryotes should really be seen as a
merger of different domains of life only
then will you probably truly understand
what makes a eukaryotic cell tick right
but where the where the current model is
different from what it was before
is that previously used to people used
to think you really had in terms of
genetic similarity three domains of life
your head bacteria you had Archaea and
you had eukaryotes
and that that sort of tripartite view
implies that all the eukaryotes are more
closely related to each other than they
are to any of the Ikea and all the Ikea
are more close related right to each
other than they are to any pocket and so
on what we know now is that actually
um some Archaea are more close related
to eukaryotes than they are to other Arc
here so in terms of the genetic
similarity of the
um the eukaryotes Nestle within a
broader uh archaeal diversity so that's
really
um what's changed over the last 10 years
or so in terms of our appreciation
um of how eukaryote care relate and is
it am I correcting remembering that it
was the development of eukaryotes that
took so long in the evolution of life
that life itself began not too long
after the Earth sat down and got formed
but then for a long time it was all
prokaryotes yes although again that
that's not really my area of expertise
and I have to say if you go billions of
years to the Past you have no fossil
record to rely on you're just making
inferences from the genomes that you can
observe today so you're looking at
current genome sequences reconstructing
relationships and trying to understand
how these relate to each other in terms
of time and often you have to make some
assumptions so for example how many
changes do you see in a genome over time
and do you know very little about how
regular those changes in the DNA really
are and whether what you can see at the
moment you can extrapolate two billion
years backwards so there's in terms of
how how long bacteria exists before
eukaryotes emerged people have been
debating but the margins of error are
probably quite large okay that's fair I
do apologize for asking these questions
outside your expertise but you know
they're all it's all biology to me like
I can't see the fine distinctions there
so uh yeah we'll get to your real
election I'm sure I'm sure I'll get
angry emails about uh from people who
know what they're talking about but
that's fine that's part of yeah that's
just part of the of the bargain here
um so and therefore I'm going to ask you
one more question which I think might
not be in your area but then we'll move
on
um it's stop I'll stop no commenting you
so you could do that that's fair be a
good politician
um is it correct that multicellular
organisms are always eukaryotes so in
terms of multicellular organisms
um that so I'm trying to Define it for
myself because I know that there are
bacteria for example that can occur in
um I want to say assemblages of multiple
cells and you can also have assemblages
where you have defined roles of
individual cells within that assemblage
okay right yeah
um so that that does exist in bacteria
but it's so what makes a multicellular
organism I'm having to think here so I
think I'll stop with the fact with the
observation that bacteria can form
assemblages with specialized cell types
um but I'm not sure to what extent that
answers your question yeah no I mean
that's okay I think you know this is why
biology is messy and it's much better to
be a physicist because the boundaries
are a little bit fuzzy the overalling
majority of what we think of is
multicellular organisms are in fact
eukaryotes but there are I think that's
that's that's that's fair to say yeah I
mean that's in a way what makes biology
interesting right it's a science of
exceptionalism exactly you can always
find something that violates your
um perceived wisdom okay good so uh
thank you for indulging my um fairly
Elementary but still difficult questions
because biology is hard but but let's
get into you know something that that I
think is more in your specific domain of
expertise you know the what's going on
inside these eukaryotic cells in
particular and we'll get to some of the
cool ways in which they show up in the
other cells also but
I guess as an open-ended question what
is the person on the street need to know
about the substructure within a typical
eukaryotic cell you know we mentioned
that there is a nucleus that's obviously
important we mentioned mitochondria
there's a cell wall I'm sure there's
many other things going on but I'll let
you suggest which ones are the most
important
um yeah I think there's a number of
compartments that do dedicated things so
for example
um what's called the Golgi
structures that are
responsible if you want for producing
proteins that get secreted structures in
which
proteins or other things get digested
um
so it's a depending on the eukaryote you
look at you might find different
structures certain plants you have
chloroplasts which are key for for
photosynthesis
um and then if you if you look around
you'll you'll find some structures and
some organisms that you
um don't see in others
um but that structure is that sort of
compartmentalization if you want is also
present even though you don't have a
nucleus
um in in prokaryotes so you also have
different structures and those that do
specialize things
and the where it gets really interesting
to me is the structures the kind of
a Shepherd I guess is the right word and
protect our DNA you know we we always
like to brag or or Amaze ourselves by if
you took a human DNA and you stretched
it out it would be very long do you know
the actual number I don't think I do oh
I don't know uh so in the meter range
um yeah something like that yeah so from
a single cell that is if you took the
DNA from all the cells you'd stretch
um you know I don't want to give a
number but it's it's a long it's a long
journey
um yes so I think that the first thing
to to mention here is that DNA has to do
a number of different things right one
is just
um as a material for passing on your
genetic information to the Next
Generation right the other is to decode
the genes that you need at the right
time in the right place and throughout
that Journey you want to protect that
DNA
from damage from if you're a single cell
organisms you might care about UV damage
for example
um or most most all organisms care about
water damage so
oxidative stress you want to protect the
DNA from that so there's an intrinsic
trade-off here between
making all that information accessible
to the Machinery that transcribes it but
also protecting it right and allowing
that information to be accessed at the
right time in the right place while
suppressing other bits of of the DNA
which is why the DNA doesn't float
around nakedly in the nucleus or in
prokaryotes just in the cell but it's
associated with a number of different
proteins that impart some organization
onto that DNA to the pattern pattern
access is I think I think about it
mostly As Access Control when you see
some of the relationships between the
different pieces of substructure and I
was looking at complete maps of the
metabolic pathways in some of the
archaea it's almost enough to make you
believe in intelligent design isn't it I
mean there's a lot going on there that
is very intricately connected
I I often have the opposite feeling good
but if I if somebody had designed this
intelligently it would have it would
have been much simpler there's so many
things that I especially in metabolism
that make no obvious sense to me but I
haven't I mean I have no training in
that but that's fair enough um there's
there's so much historical contingency
in many parts of genome Evolution it's
often so convoluted that's often hard to
dissect what really is is going on okay
that that is fair enough I mean it's I
guess the right thing to say is there is
complexity there right it does it
actually doesn't seem very designed but
there are different pieces that manage
somehow to work together yes correct
it's a it's often extremely complex
um and we understand a sliver of the
complexity I think especially if it
comes to the things and it's going back
to the point I made earlier that maybe
we just haven't measured so people on
again only recently have started to
assist automatically ask what are the
small molecules that are present in the
cell like okay we can look at DNA we can
look at RNA we can look at proteins but
there's so many other things in the cell
ions metabolites what do they all do and
how do they interact how do they
interact with proteins and the DNA and
how does it all hang together and to get
again you know technological advances
driving our understanding of what the
cell's doing only with the ability to
measure those different metabolas are we
getting a clearer understanding of what
might be happening and that raises a
question that's been in the back of my
mind actually you know we say that the
DNA encodes information that governs the
structure of the cell Etc and even the
function I suppose later on down the
line how how exclusive or exhaustive is
that uh in in the sense that are there
aspects of the cell that are just
spontaneously self-organizing like you
know the the shape of the cell walls or
whatever or does the DNA really like
micromanage everything that is going on
in all the different parts no it's not
and that's that's obviously also an
aspect of physics here right so for
example when when tissues form the way
they form is is very much patterned by
how they arrange against each other how
they arrange against a surface of other
cells
um and that's that that's building plan
is not necessarily directly encoded in
the in the DNA but it's part of the
history that the deist DNA has come to
work with so if you because you have to
have the DNA and transplanted into
something if you took right DNA from a
bacterium and put it in the context of a
eukaryotic cell what would that
actually do
um and people have asked that question
to some extent not quite over the
distance but they take a human
chromosome put it in the mouse how does
that Mouse recognize this new DNA can
that DNA instruct the cell to do certain
things and you know it it works to some
extent if this information is not
critical but you cannot just remove yeah
the entire genome from a human cell put
a bacterial DNA in there and suddenly
the human cell will turn into bacterial
cell so there's this you know if you
want historical patterning the cell has
to be there for the DNA to to act act on
this provide the instructions that are
needed to build another type of the same
cell yeah okay good yeah the DNA is is
tailor-made or vice versa for the cell I
don't know they're they it's not one
size fits all yeah exactly okay good so
let's let's start addressing this
question of how we take a meter long
molecule of DNA and squeeze it in to the
nucleus of a cell is this something that
we understand yeah I think we understand
it reasonably well so I think that the
first thing to think about is DNA is
think about as a sort of rubber cubing
right so it's a bit stiff it's a bit
stiff you can fold it over but not quite
as a very sharp band angles second thing
to understand is that it's a highly
negatively charged because there's
phosphates in there okay so if you now
have it a molecule that's negatively
charged throughout this whole Rod right
and try to bend it over there's actually
repulsion right so you have to
neutralize that charge how can you
neutralize that charge
first answers ions so you can have
positively charged ions that um I guess
yeah yeah and it turns out that because
of the geometry of the DNA
um
ions with a valency of
um one so does don't really do it for
you so you want something that has a
higher valency so more positively
charges so two you're getting getting to
the point where you might be doing
something
um but if you really want a compact DNA
you go three and higher and you can
provide those charges either through
through some ions directly or through
proteins that also can be charged so for
example proteins that encode a lot of
arginine are positively charged and
they're really good at compacting DNA so
for example
um one cell where DNA is extremely
compacted is sperm so sperm cells have a
protein called protamine and proteins
are extremely highly charged almost just
arginines and they can really Clump
together the DNA really nicely the the
trick here is that if you're a sperm the
DNA is if your DNA in a sperm you don't
really have to do all that much
or you want to be is good or you want to
be as compact you want to reach your
destination and exactly
um metabolism is still there you can
still
um swim but you don't need to encode any
new information you don't have to be
responsive to an environment just swim
swim swim until you reach your targets
fingers crossed right so the the key for
other cells that need to either
dynamically respond to the environment
or replicate or do something else is
that just compacting doesn't work for
you so you need to be Compact and
provide access to Machinery in the right
time at the right place so our cells in
our body
sperm apart don't have proteamines but
they package the DNA using a different
type of protein it's called a histone so
you have histones that assemble into a
complex called the nucleosome and they
wrap the DNA around that complex and
again the histones have positively
charged amino acids so that they partly
neutralize the the charge so in in
eukaryotes histones are Universal as far
as we know with with a quirky exception
which I can tell you about if you want
um so all your carriers except in one
case that we know of organize
their chromosomes at a basic level using
those histone proteins and the exception
is called
dinoflagellates they live in their sort
of unicellular creatures live in the sea
um they are responsible for algal blooms
for example in some instances
um and they still encode histones
because you can find histones if you
look at their genomes but they don't
seem to be using them for packaging
instead it appears that for some somehow
they acquired A protein that comes
originally from a virus and that protein
has taken over the packaging function
and they package their DNA most of the
DNA very tightly in the sort of almost
crystalline State
and how exactly gene expression works in
those organisms I think is something
people still try to figure out okay I I
mean I really love that because I think
I understood something and probably
because it was sounding pretty physicsy
there for a while which
should talk more about ions yeah as long
as there's electrical charges repelling
each other I'm I'm very much on board so
yeah so the DNA by itself doesn't want
to be compacted because it's like
charges repel and it's negatively
charged so you can Shield that with some
positive charges but you in some sense
unless you're a sperm cell like you said
you don't want to be too efficient at
that because the DNA has a role to play
you want to protect it and you want to
Shield it and you want to compactify it
but you also want to let the cell access
it to figure out what to do about which
proteins to build right exactly
um yeah and so you have some special
instances like sperm or say spores
bacterial spores or where you are sort
of a dormant State you want to survive
some harsh conditions you initiate a
spot relation program you package up
your DNA you're fine you just wait until
some trigger maybe water maybe some
suitable conditions activate you and you
can
restart your normal growth cycle again
so these histones seem like kind of a
big deal uh I'll be very honest and
confess that before 2023 I never heard
of a histone or at least I didn't
remember uh what histones were so do we
know where they came from do we know
what were the first cells uh that had
the idea of using these particular
histones or proteins right correct
they're proteins and as I said there you
find them in in all eukaryotes but you
also find them
in many many are here including the Ikea
we talked about earlier but many other
are cares with the quite widespread
um and I think it's
um fair to say that most people assume
that they are being used for the same
purpose so in part compacting The genome
and controlling gene expression but
actually we don't really know that yet
um and in samakia they might be used in
a different way to others so if I and I
tell you that
um with the following uh for the
following reason so if you look at
archael genomes you have many where you
find the histone but then actually if
you actually look at how many of those
proteins you find in a given archaeal
cell that can vary quite a lot so some
are care
Express minute quantities of the histone
so there's no way they're using it in
the same manner that you carry it to
okay so they're just too lowly abandoned
to be used as a sort of packaging agent
might actually be doing just that they
might have histones that that code or
wrap most of the DNA so maybe some uh
okay are way back in the day first hit
upon the idea of making histones and
they put them to various usage uses and
then at some point they realized oh this
is really really good for packing DNA
and the eukaryotes borrowed that yeah or
if you think about how we think
eukaryogenesis happened and um the the
common ancestor of all eukaryotes might
have started out from a ground state
where most of the DNA was passed up in a
similar manner than it is now I said
inherited would have been a better yeah
having having said that there's a big
gap in our knowledge and our
understanding of
um not histones themselves but the
transition between archaea and how they
use histones and eukaryotes and how they
use systems so in eukaryotes in all
eukaryotes you have a very well
conserved complex of different histones
so they all fit together there's four
different types they all fit together in
the same manner in all eukaryotes
they're always arranged eight the eight
histones four different types two of
each assemble into the same complex in
our care you also have histones but they
seem to be combining much more freely
there's no no fixed size of what we call
a nucleosome so this eukaryotic histone
DNA complex seems about much more sort
of versatile in a way so how exactly
archaea eukaryotes got stuck with this
particular architecture is something we
still don't understand is it plausible
that we can think of the archaea as
little experimental Laboratories trying
out different things and once they hit
upon this particular configuration of
his stones that is used in eukaryotes it
was both very useful and even helped the
initial Evolution into eukaryotic life
it's a possibility so people have
certainly suggested that histones might
have been beneficial for eukaryogenesis
yeah
um to what extent the specific
architecture of the histum DNA complex
is useful
um I I don't know
um but it's certainly been suggested
um what I think is interesting an
interesting distinction between
eukaryotes and prokaryotes when it comes
to histones is that in eukaryotes
histones give you something like
localized access control so imagine you
have your genome and most of that genome
is wrapped up in histones so now these
histones have flexible protein tails and
those Tails can get modified so other
enzyme times other proteins can put
information on those tails and they can
do that in a locally specific manner so
for example I can put a what's called a
post-translational modification on the
histones associated with a chunk of DNA
that codes for Gene of interest and that
modification will be recognized and shut
down that Gene that gives you a
flexibility of sort of localized control
because you can modify some histones in
some places but leave other others
untouched and that as far as we know
doesn't really exist in Arc here at
least it hasn't been hasn't been
demonstrated so we can maybe change the
overall expression of the histones or
change different types but the default
assumption is that if we do that we
affect the state of the what's called
chromatin so the DNA protein complex we
change that globally rather than locally
I see
that's great so the histones are not
only uh an efficient packing Matrix for
the DNA but they offer some measure of
control that we didn't otherwise have
because we were talking before about
gene expression and how it's not the DNA
is not just a passive thing there we
sort of pick and choose how is it is
expressed and the histones are playing a
role there exactly and that's why I
think arguably most people are
interested in histones and eukaryotes
because they you could see them as a
platform almost for the integration of
different types of information so
something happens on the in the outside
world signaling Cascades and the cell
get triggered that end up in histones
being modified recognized by the
proteins and then that particular Gene
starts getting expressed or shut down
so a couple of weeks ago a few weeks ago
I was reading a tweet by Theodore ordnov
who's a previous mindscape guest an
expert in crispr and Gene editing and so
forth and even you know through the
medium of Twitter I could tell that he
was jumping up and down in excitement he
said oh my goodness we're gonna have to
rewrite all the textbooks this is really
crucial and what he was pointing to was
a paper of yours that says okay now we
found that there are histones in
bacteria as well not just Archaea and
eukaryotes and it seems that they're
even important to the bacteria they're
they're functional in some way uh tell
us about that well I has left to get
past the point of uh imagining if you're
the owner of uh jumping up and down at
Joy
um so so yeah so
I mentioned before you find histones in
all eukaryotes in many many arc here but
I think it's fair to say that most
people would have would think that
histones are absent from bacteria and
that is true for the vast majority of
bacteria
um about
98 or so of bacteria don't have histones
but it turns out that if you
systematically look through a collection
of bacterial genomes you find sequences
in those genomes that comparatively look
like a histone and people had observed
that two three years ago just through
bioinformatics and maybe at the time
that paper didn't get the coverage it
maybe deserved what was unclear is
um whether these things that looked like
histones really were histones so whether
they would fold up into the same
three-dimensional structure and what
they did if anything so because
sometimes you have instances where
um you find
genes getting passed around so what we
call horizontal transfer from bacteria
to bacteria or Archaea and maybe they
pick up some genetic material for
material from eukaryotes and maybe they
just hang around in a genome and don't
end up doing very much
um but um a postdoc of mine Antoine Jose
um started looking at that more
seriously and found that actually if you
look at certain types of bacteria you
find them quite well conserved so you
they're not just present in a single
genome but in close related genes as
well and if you measure their abundance
they're extremely abundant and if
something is manufactured in large
quantities by the cell it's probably
useful because otherwise
you get rid of it the cell doesn't tend
to churn out any old crap it doesn't
yeah
um so then we went went on in with
collaborators
um in the US
um and and more locally try to a test
whether those histones were useful to
the cell and it turns out that they are
so we couldn't get rid of the histone
Gene so normally if you have a gene that
is not vital to Cellular functions in
the in the laboratory environment you
can go in cut that piece of DNA out of
the genome and the bacterium would be
fine just keep on growing
we tried doing that didn't work and we
tried multiple times and it always
failed so that tells you that it's
essential for for growth under the
conditions what we have it makes sense
it's extremely highly expressed it's
going to be useful for something
um
and then um our collaborators in the US
um Sean laosen and Karen Luger showed
that indeed that
um that piece of sequence that looked
like a histone when you compare the
sequence actually folded up into
something that looks remarkably like a
histone from eukaryotes with some
important but subtle tweaks so it's a a
shorter version of the Hidden basis okay
so what is the moral of this story so
you said that not all bacteria have
these histones but they the histones do
seem to cross the lines of the kingdoms
they're in all the eukaryotes I forget
whether it's all or or some of the
archaea and some of the bacteria uh yeah
some um many many the majority of
um Ikea have histones all eukaryotes
um and a few selected
um types of bacteria I'm not sure what
the what the overall moral of the story
is except to say that biological
um conceived perceived wisdoms are meant
to be broken
so so some some people when their
comment ones are saying
um oh as a Dogma defying Discovery I
wouldn't go that far because a Dogma to
me is something that you postulate
cannot be different and nothing in
biology would have made the case that
histones cannot exist in bacteria right
what what people were surprised about
that
um they hadn't been observed before but
they're actually there and I think that
it's probably too for many enzymes which
were once thought to be unique to group
a and then I found in some of Group B
and also tend to uh
um transpire to play an important role
in that group
um and second moral of the story maybe
is that if Parts in one organism turn
out to be very useful and can be passed
around through this horizontal transfer
process
um they might well be used in other
genomes not necessarily for the same
purpose
um but what's what's sort of intriguing
in a way is that the bacteria that we
found have those histones they also in
many instances have a life stage that to
me is almost a bit like sperm okay so
one bacterium for example is called
delovibrio
um and it's a super interesting
bacterium and that it's a predator of
other bacteria so it swims around in an
almost like a sperm-like fashion swims
around hunting for prey it attaches to
another bacterium drills a hole into the
outside of the bacterium sneaks inside
seals the neck behind and then it starts
to eat the bacterium From the Inside by
secreting by secreting enzymes that chop
up its prey so the the key Point here is
that you have two different life cycle
stages the sort of sperm-like free
swimming attack sale as they're called
and the thing that replicates actively
inside the host and the small attack
cell is really small with a highly
condensed chromatin so initially we're
thinking well maybe the histone is
useful in bringing about that compaction
we we don't think that's the entirety of
the story
but it's certainly an intriguing lead
into trying to understand why the why
the histone was was acquired by bacteria
like that I never knew that there were
bacterial Predators I thought the
bacterial bacteria were all vegans
essentially that I guess it's a it's a
bacterium eat bacterium world out there
um yeah so to be fair like before we
started working on this project and
discovered
um that histones were present in this
this particular bacterium I hadn't
really heard of it before
um but that's again a pleasure of of
biology that's endlessly fascinating
novelty I mean maybe we should pause to
talk a little about this whole big idea
of horizontal Gene transfer or or just
more generally the idea that you know we
have we've been taught again in our high
school education that there is a tree of
life and you know one organism evolves
from another one and then they a branch
off and they're separate but down there
in the unicellular World it seems a lot
more
sociable people cells share genetic
information they they pick up tricks uh
substructures proteins you know what
have you is this is this something we're
beginning to discover or do we have a
good handle on how it's working is it is
it just amusing or is it crucially
important what's going on I think it's
uh it's in many instances crucely
important both to understand
um how Evolution happened in in bacteria
and in unicellular organisms in
particular it's important to understand
because one of the key aspects of that
is
that pathogenic
elements genes that help in pathogenesis
get shared around so often bacteria
acquire certain genes and then become
pathogenic and can pass them on to other
bacteria
so it's so interesting from a human
health perspective yeah
um
um and I think overall we have a good
handle on the mechanisms of how this
happens
um what we have still beginning to
understand is how how common really
um that phenomenon is not only in
bacteria but also in eukaryotes
um and what the implications of that are
for our understanding of of early
Evolution
um because the further back you go the
harder is to envisage the sort of
tree-like bifurcating structure that you
that you just mentioned so I guess I was
going to say that it seems like that
grown-up eukaryotes are a little bit
more settled in their ways and less
likely to do this kind of transfer but
you just said it happens is it is it
less common or are there good examples
um so it happens uh it happens
frequently
um in some species so again maybe in a
way
um the the way to understand it is that
as humans for example we have a large
part part of our body dedicated to just
you know running around doing things
yeah and only a smart small part of our
body is dedicated to making genetic
material that gets passed on to the next
Generation so if you are a piece of DNA
and you want to get into that specific
population that sells that gets to the
Next Generation you have a whole lot of
body to get through so our J our
germline if you want is sequestered away
um and quite protected in that in that
way much more protected than yeast for
example single celled organisms if you
think about uh
acquiring naked DNA from the outside
much harder to see that happening for
for the human genome than it is for
yeast cell
um
so that's coming to the mechanisms of
how this happens right so acquisition of
of DNA from the environment is one of
them
um DNA doesn't tend to be super stable
in many environments
um so often it gets degraded the other
is direct Bridges between between
different
um bacterial cells for example so
bacteria do a thing called conjugation
where they link up neighboring cells and
then they can pass genetic material
through those cells and then I think one
of the key mechanisms is actual viruses
or what you call phage in bacteria so
they can pick up when the infected
bacterial cell they pick up a fragment
of the genome
phase replicates a new infection cycle
starts and then it might actually inject
that piece of DNA that it previously
picked up into a new hose that might
then if the infection fails integrate
that bit of DNA into its genome so yeah
different ways of sharing things around
and my impression is that not only can
little bits of DNA get shared around but
they could even discover new uses for
them when they're in a different kind of
cell because like you mentioned before
like a DNA out there in the in the wild
is not doing that much it depends a lot
on the particular kind of cellular
environment it's in
um yeah and it depends on what sort of
protein for example we're talking about
so something that uh might be almost
immediately useful is a single enzyme so
say your quiet enzyme and the enzyme can
degrade some antibiotic and you're in an
environment where you have to resist
um being killed by the antibiotic
immediately useful if you are part of a
large complex of several dozens of
proteins and you get transferred as a
single Gene you might find yourself in
the context where actually you don't
quite know what your purpose is to put
it in the sort of anthropomorphic way
right I felt that way yeah
um the the the genetic context in which
those transfers happen the environmental
cortex whether that bit of DNA is going
to be useful or just selected out
obviously matters a lot so that explains
in part why organisms that are closer to
each other both in terms of their
genetics sequence similarity but also
until of that environment tend to
exchange genes more frequently because
something that has proven useful to a
bacterium that lives at 80 degree might
also prove more useful to a bacterium
that Canon that lives at 80 degree then
RK on that lives at 30 degrees so since
we're near the end of the podcast here I
will once again be very unfair and ask
you questions that are not necessarily
within your professional wheelhouse but
given all this given what we've learned
about you know the sharing of different
genes and different mechanisms and the
appearance of histones where they
weren't predicted
uh is it is there any implication of
this for the origin of Life how the
whole thing got started or just a better
understanding of the nature of Life
which hopefully someday will lead to a
better understanding how it might have
originated and the answer would be no
you mean in relation to horizontal Gene
transfer well just everything we've been
talking about yeah horizontal Gene
transfer but just also the the mixing
and matching of different parts of the
genome uh or the the repurposing of
proteins which I think is is fascinating
so I think when it comes to
understanding the origin of life if
anything it complicates matters because
our ability to reconstruct those very
deep ancestral States currently depends
on our on comparing genome sequences
yeah and making assumption about what
those genes did in the past and those
assumptions as we just highlighted right
might be wrong what I think well I think
this sort of knowledge of repurposing
um horizontal Gene transfer what some
people call Moonlighting so a protein
having maybe one main function but also
being able to do something else and
eventually it might focus on that
secondary task
um would be interesting in a synthetic
apology context so when it comes to
engineering desirable properties into
microbes so you as you could say so you
could say how do I build the smallest
genome I possibly can that can do X Y
and Z right survive at 80 degrees but
replicate very fast so I think a better
understanding of the the toolkit and how
it can be shared around and how it can
be repurposed actually give us a gives
us a much larger selection of
potentially useful molecular components
that we could use to to build those
those synthetic organ and that would be
that's a very very good point I mean
that's that's clearly going to be one of
the growth areas in in the decades to
come right uh not just
um editing existing DNA to tweak you
know blue eyes versus green eyes versus
brown eyes but making new functions
right making kind of dramatically new
organisms may be yeah and I think
ultimately that that ability and maybe
also playfulness Us in in creating those
new organisms will then enable us to go
back and say well actually now I've
understand much better about the rules
in which I can combine those different
elements what does that tell me about
what I think went on two billion years
ago right it's maybe sort of
um what do you call it learning by
building right so you try to assemble
the system maybe use parts from our care
and bacteria and eukaryotes see how they
can or cannot work together and then end
up with a much clearer understanding of
the rules of life if you want and how
they might have emerged ancestrally you
know it's the biologists because it does
seem very messy and hard to understand
to me but it's also very clear that
really important questions are being not
just asked but answered in real time so
it's great to get a little view of of
the front lines and that so Tobias
vernica thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
again
[Music]
mama